[inaudible]
what do I do when I feel unfocused or overwhelmed?
There are a few things. Uh, first I have a short checklist.
Am I eating enough? All right,
so it's very fashionable with intermittent fasting to skip breakfast,
skip that meal, skip another meal for myself,
I've realized in less I am in ketosis unless I'm on a ketogenic diet or fasting
or have ketones in my blood, which is an alternative fuel to glucose,
I need to eat. And uh, of course you can supplement with exotic in as ketones.
But am I eating enough?
If I skip breakfast and it's 1:00 PM and I haven't had lunch and I'm feeling
unfocused or overwhelmed,
I probably don't need to sit there and journal on my existential dilemmas.
I need to eat some fucking macadamia nuts and maybe have some beans or salad or
something like that. All right? So simple, simple, simple. Uh,
the second would be am I consuming too much caffeine?
Real simple for me. If I'm feeling anxious, overwhelmed,
very often if I want to achieve a more zen-like state,
there are at least two things I can do. And one is meditate twice a day,
which I like to do. Doesn't always happen.
Meditate twice a day and do all of these other things related to cultivating
peace of mind. The second one is stop consuming so much caffeine.
All right, real, real, real simple.
Then last are a few tactical and strategic questions and being overwhelmed and
unfocused I think are quite different things. Typically,
sometimes they come along together, they're two questions, uh,
or I should say two pairs or groups of questions that I use a lot.
The first one is an 80 20 analysis and there are two questions as part of them
and I put this on paper always on paper because I want to trap my thoughts on
paper to see if they hold any weight to see if there's any insight to see what
is ridiculous.
Maybe I have worries that once I put them down or really unfounded and kind of
ludicrous. First question is,
what are the 20% of activities or people that are producing 80% or more of the
results and positive emotional states that I want?
The positive emotional states part is really important. All right,
so you spend one or two pages on that. The second part is the opposite.
What are the 20% of activities,
responsibilities or people that are producing 80% or more of the pain,
the headache and the negative emotional states that I would prefer not to have
do another page or two. And then the last question,
if you're engaged with a specific project or relationship,
could be anything really is very simple.
It's what would this look if it were easy?
And I think very much if we're type a personality, we've competed in school,
we've competed next, we've competed in Y and z.
We are trained by ourselves to believe that if we're not red lining,
if we're not overcome with effort,
that we're not doing a good job, we're not trying hard enough.
And I think that often leads us to seek complicated paths with many,
many moving pieces. So what would this look like if it were easy?
So for instance,
if I'm having trouble with a book and I have three months left to write it,
I'll ask myself, what would this look like if it were easy?
What if I had to finish this book in a week?
If I had a gun to my head or a gun to my dog's head or Molly and I had to save
Molly, what would I do? All right, you have a week. That's it, period.
How would you write this book? And that carrot gets rid of a lot of fluff.
And I start saying, all right,
well how could I use money instead of time to fix this problem?
How could I ask other people for help instead of trying to do it all myself in
this situation? What would this look like if it were easy?
And you can find a lot of gems that way and just expect 95% what you write down
is going to potentially be ludicrous and you should come up with the absurd,
right? Don't edit when you're putting stuff down.
But within that you might find one or two things and you're like, that's it.
Now I can say if 80% of my headache,
80% of my axed because I don't have to do it the hard way.
And then you can find an elegant solution that produces an even better product,
even better outcome.
So those are a few of the things that I regularly do when I'm feeling
overwhelmed or unfocused or distracted. Hey guys,
if you're enjoying the tips and tactics and how to on this channel or in the
podcast, the Tim Ferriss show, I made this for you, tribe of mentors,
short advice from the best in the world. This is the book that I wanted to read.
So I went out and I put it together,
created a dream list of 130 of the best at what they do.
People who are icons, legends and ask them all the same questions.
These are people in some cases I wanted to reach out to my whole life ranges
from many, many billionaires, cofounders of every company imaginable,
elite athletes ranging from surfing to tennis to power lifting. Everything else,
country stars, actors, directors, and you can spot the pattern.
So some of my friends have said, this is the easiest to read,
most useful book that I've put together yet.
So checking out tribal mentors.com you can find sample chapters,
the whole list of mentors, everything, tribe, mentors.com.